foreign
[Music]
I'm a software engineer at Voltron data
and I'm also one of the maintainers on
the Apache Arrow project and I work
mainly on the r package
um so I started learning about 12 years
ago and I just got so excited about the
idea of Open Source I went from being
like this passive consumer of software
to now kind of having this thing that I
could kind of like pull apart and kind
of it was like seeing the Matrix seeing
inside kind of all these functions and
things like that
but despite that been quite a while ago
it took me about six more years I'd say
to really start to connect with the our
communities and another few years on top
of that to make my first contribution so
kind of what I want to talk to you about
today is kind of the things that got in
my way and stopped me getting involved
with contributing to open source a bit
sooner when I probably actually could
have
um and actually like it's it's been so
beneficial to me I almost wish I had
sooner
but first
um so um in the way that everybody does
science I wanted to do a Twitter poll so
question for my our stats folks who have
contributed to open source how many
years have you been using open source
libraries for before you made your first
contribution and actually it was pretty
easy interesting to see that it was
pretty nice to see that for most people
pretty soon actually two to three years
of using open source libraries before
they kind of really got involved
but actually you know it's quite a lot
of people in a similar situation to
where I was where six or more years
before they kind of really kind of made
that First Leap
so I'm going to start off just by
talking about kind of why contribute to
open source and the benefits it's had
for me but before I go into that I just
want to start with a bit of disclaimer
like I'm not saying that contributing to
open source is necessary to be a good
software engineer or a good data
scientist it's absolutely not I think
there's a certain amount of privilege
being involved with even having the time
to do so alongside everything else so
that's not what I'm going for here
um but going back to kind of like what
I've gotten out of contributing to open
source and I feel like it's been the
best learning experience of my career
um definitely kind of you know
contributing kind of code and non-code
things and getting feedback from people
has been the biggest acceleration of my
development as a software engineer and
working in public is great you know I
figure out something that's taken me
ages and I blog about it and then
somebody's like okay I get it now really
rewarding and again it's great to be
part of community and I think as well
it's it's great to have that proof of
your skills like I'm not the most
necessarily confident person as a
software engineer but having those sort
of bragging rights you know like I've
kind of made those contributions to that
project okay well I guess I must know
what I'm doing some of the time then and
also just like giving back to projects
that have helped me in my work before
okay so that that's kind of the benefit
but what are the kind of things that
have kind of maybe got in my way or some
quite common complaints
so like I think one of the flip sides of
Open Source being this kind of massive
network of self-governing communities is
that it has been quite kind of okay in
some bits
um to you know have kind of quite strong
personalities and people kind of not
behaving amazingly
um in some bits anyway so I think I
definitely had that question you know
are people going to be friendly or mean
um there's also the question of not
knowing how so I was at a point where I
could write functions and even write our
packages but I've not made a pull
request to a project yet
um other questions for things like what
if I don't have the skills to do this
what if I don't know where to start and
even just that fear that like working in
public is scary I get to share my
successes but I also kind of sharing my
failures a bit
so just to get kind of one barrier out
of the way if it is literally just the
process of how do I make a pull request
to a project that is stopping you from
contributing to open source
um I'd say please do check out the first
contributions repo
um that's kind of looked after by
forwards so I was involved in kind of
making the r version of this and
basically it takes you to the process of
making a pull request and so if you
already know a bit of git and know how
to use GitHub that is all you need to
kind of just walk through the kind of
mechanical steps for it
but actually I think the things that
really hold people back from getting
involved aren't kind of the actual
process things and it's more these kind
of concerns or worries so like the main
book of this talk is going to be
basically about things that I now know
that I wish I'd known before
okay so the first big question I had is
how to pick where to get involved and
what to work on and I think this is just
really complicated by maybe the view
that I had of Open Source and I I really
had this kind of slightly misguided View
at first that open source is one big
community and that's just not true there
are lots of Open Source sub-communities
and even within languages with an R we
see this right
um but I think even kind of stepping
back from that kind of my next view of
Open Source wasn't quite right either so
to kind of illustrate it so this is a
screenshot from the movie Mean Girls
um now if you've not seen that like I'm
sure everybody at some point has seen
some TV show or movie where you've got
this kind of like American High School
cafeteria and the new kids working
through and it's like these people going
to let me sit at their table or are they
not and that feeling of you know these
people are kind of mean and these people
are kind of nice and things like that
and this metaphor completely breaks down
because everybody's nerds here
um but the point was like kind of
viewing it as a kind of these people are
mean and awful and these people are
lovely over here isn't quite right
um I think with a lot of projects it's
easy to forget like a lot of projects
kind of staffed by volunteers and
there's a lot of reasons why kind of
some projects just don't want new
contributors so they might be going
through a design phase they might just
be really small and it does take effort
to board a new contributor so I kind of
came to realize that is okay but then of
course like the next obvious question is
so if some projects don't want new
compute contributors then how do I find
the ones that do
and actually that was way easier to
answer than I thought so
um they'll tell you so for example this
is an issue from the arrow project and
this is one that we've labeled good
first issue to say you know this is a
good place to get started getting
involved and again similarly his I think
this is an old one but this is from
deeplya and it's been labeled both good
first issue and help wanted like clear
signaling like we want people to get
involved here and I will say like
projects that don't have these labels it
doesn't mean they don't want new
contributors but if this is a concern of
yours this is kind of an easy way to
kind of figure it out
so the next question I guess then I had
is what to contribute and I think um
commonly given advice that I think is
good advice is all about starting small
buildup trust you know show people
you've read the guidelines and you can
kind of like go from small things and
bigger from there
I think one thing that was really
important for me though actually is it
is way easier to contribute to packages
that you use yourself and so my first
contribution was to the broom package
and that went well and everything but
there were points during that kind of
code contribution where I was like I
don't know if I can change this because
I wasn't a regular user of the package
and it would have been much easier if it
was something that had a bit more kind
of day-to-day use with and of course
like if you found problems in packages
um or bugs that you've experienced
yourself that's a really great place to
get involved kind of figuring out what's
going on fixing it submitting a pull
request equally with documentation you
find unclear I feel like if you're newer
to something you're actually an
advantage here like you're coming to
this problem with kind of like a fresh
mindset and therefore like if the
documentation doesn't make sense to you
it's probably not going to make sense to
somebody else and that's a really nice
early contribution to make
um and just in general if you've got a
specific maybe area that you've got
expertise domain knowledge that's also a
great place to go and kind of like use
that if it's a package that deals with
that
okay
so I think for me the really really
really big question um about how to get
involved was how to navigate social
dynamics and this is a really tricky one
because as I said before every project
is different and made up of quite
different people even kind of within the
same project
now this is quote that I really like
actually so this book called um working
in public by nadie agbo and if you're
interested in kind of Open Source
governance and how these things work I
would definitely recommend it really
good book but um in the book Nadia says
open source is complicated because it
contains a massive mix of both Technical
and social norms most of which player in
public and I think this really gets to
it for me like it's you know figuring
out how to kind of change something make
a function and that's one thing but just
figuring out how to be this new person
in this group and kind of go in and and
not annoy people and kind of just get
things done that can be really tricky
so one of the ways of overcoming this I
think is a lot of projects have
participated have have kind of
contributing guidelines and
documentation so I I this this is kind
of like a screenshot of a page that I
really really like actually it's um the
Apache software Foundation kind of
member participation guidelines and it
goes into detail even like to the minute
detail of kind of like how to kind of
phrase requests that kind of make
significant changes to make it kind of
as I guess as smoothly as possible
um I I they say this doesn't just apply
to Apache software Foundation project
and it's definitely worth kind of
skimming through these if that's kind of
a concern that you have yourself
but then the other thing here I think is
like sometimes just embracing imposter
syndrome like you are new to this thing
and that's great but like if you were
pretending to be somebody that was there
already what would you do
so the answer could be you can go and
read previous pull requests and previous
issues and look at the kind of things
that people do so like every different
package is going to have something
slightly different and it's always good
just to see what the conventions are and
to follow them and I will say the one
thing to kind of add to that is as a new
contributor it's sometimes better to err
on the side of over communicating rather
than under communicating because an
established kind of contributor might
kind of need to say less to get
something accepted but still I found
reading those previous PRS and issues
has been like super super useful
okay
now this is a really weird one for me um
something I've noticed and again this is
very different between different
projects but definitely on some there's
this real difference in social norms and
quite Stark differences between what
would come across a certain way in real
life versus kind of how things look in a
pull request
so to step back a second we've got these
projects that have maybe got busy
maintainers lots of different issues and
there's a certain level of bluntness
that can appear rude but is people just
trying to get through issues and just
trying to get as much done as possible
and I've definitely had to kind of come
to terms with having this real duality
of kind of maybe seeing that kind of
feedback and getting to myself and not
taking it as rude or personal or
anything like that and just seeing it
what it is but at the same time actually
not necessarily engaging that in that
communication style too much myself
because I don't like it and just because
it's the normal thing it doesn't mean I
have to do it but again I can still like
exist in that world and that is fine
so kind of my third question then
um was what does the process of getting
a pull request accepted actually look
like and this is another one where I've
really had to kind of change my I guess
the way that I view these kind of things
so previously I kind of viewed it a bit
like an essay so you know kind of you're
in school you do an essay you do your
work you check it you hand it in to
somebody and then you wait a bit and you
get it back and you've got some kind of
Mark that's an indication of your skill
or competence and that is really not a
good way to look at a pull request like
you will have a bad time if you do that
and the reason for that is like a pull
request is more like a conversation than
an essay like the back and forth and
suggestions for changing things and
taking a different approach that is part
of like one of the best things about
getting involved in open source that is
when you are really learning that is
when you're getting feedback from people
that are probably quite experienced at
this
um to improve things so yeah definitely
not treating like an essay
and I think another thing kind of around
this kind of pull request kind of
approach as well is I found that coming
from a background where I've been
working in kind of consultancy and a bit
of software engineering on proprietary
projects
working on open source libraries is a
completely different thing in some
really subtle ways and this is something
that I summarize as a task oriented
versus code oriented approach
so when I was a consultant I would be
working building things with libraries
so the focus there is getting tasks done
you know you might be building an app
for a user that needs to do a certain
thing as part of their day job
um you might have a known set of users
or at least some of them you could maybe
go sit down with them and see how they'd
normally do that task and it makes it a
bit easier really to kind of see what
they're likely to do and what they're
not likely to do and you can kind of get
away with only testing kind of like
certain paths
um in these circumstances like
dependencies can be a lot less important
like you can add in new packages and it
not be a big deal and you might be the
only maintainer or part of a small team
so you can kind of do things however you
want as long as it works but this is
like completely different now like work
in an open source libraries like your
users and your tasks are mostly unknown
which means you have to be really
rigorous with your testing and even kind
of preventing like paths that you think
no one will ever take or testing things
that you think no one other use actually
does become quite important
um there's often kind of a need to
really avoid adding extra dependencies
here but that can lead to really good
things so I think sometimes it can be
easy to say right I can't get this
working with this package let's just use
this other one or a bit from both but
when you're working on kind of Open
Source Library you can and can't do that
but that forces you then to learn to
work with the tools that you've got in
front of you and learn that kind of last
10 of a library to get tasks done and I
think again that's been something that's
been really valuable for me
and also just this idea that you're
writing code that isn't kind of your
code this is to be maintained by kind of
maybe yourself but other people and the
community and that means you can't have
like these maybe weird idiosyncrasies or
kind of code smells and you're going to
be a bit more strict about these kind of
things and I think just kind of
realizing that it's a really different
kind of mindset between these two things
kind of makes it a bit easier to accept
what kind of might seem like pedantry
sometimes but it's actually like for a
really good purpose
but actually like this even isn't even
the right question
like you could submit a pull request to
a project and it might not get accepted
and that could be a good thing it could
I don't know you could try to implement
something and it doesn't quite work but
it exposes something else in the package
that actually needs changing and
updating and that's a helpful
contribution right you figured something
out that can make this software better
and actually I think the question should
be like how do I make a meaningful
contribution
because actually when I think about it I
feel really good about kind of the code
that I've kind of contributed towards
kind of Apache our own and stuff like
that but actually I feel like some of my
most meaningful open source
contributions have nothing to do with
code like I love writing blog posts when
I've learned something that I found
difficult and then somebody else is like
yeah no that makes sense to me now
finally like I love improving
documentation and taking that kind of
beginner's mindset
um even like tweeting about a bit of
functionality that is like not well
advertised and somebody's suddenly like
I can now achieve something with that I
feel like that's kind of meaningful
so kind of to summarize then um open
source is about people like there isn't
a single open source Community there's a
lot of different sub communities within
things and there's no one-size-fits-all
approach to saying you should do this
here or you should behave like that in
that way it's about kind of just
figuring it out for the thing that
you're actually looking at the time
um I think especially maybe as a new
more nervous person like just find
communities that you want to be part of
and want you to be part of them
um also just like remember everybody is
new at some point and I think that once
you have done the work of reading the
guidelines and kind of a few previous
pull requests and approaches like after
that there's a point at which you just
have to jump right in and go for it and
kind of then welcome that kind of code
review conversation but as much as I'm
talking about code now like open source
contributions are about way more than
just code and that is definitely
something to keep in mind
okay thank you
[Applause]
[Music]